matthieu delormeau donc tu as décidé de
mettre quitté l'année prochaine a priori
qu'une vraie alors pourquoi
non parce que c'est vrai qu'il veut il
veut il veut changer de vie il se pose
beaucoup de questions ah ben voilà on a
été coupé les têtes a été coupée on
n'entend plus attendu maintenant là oui
je t'entends mathieu alors qu'elle
pensait pas si c'est vrai que j'ai j'ai
eu une vie pendant dix ans dans la
finance
pendant dix ans dans la télévision celle
de la finance m'ennuyer 7 de la
télévision m'a passionné mais c'est vrai
que j'ai souvent fait les choses un peu
par obligation et à la base dans mes
rêves vous avez toujours voulu quand
j'ai commencé à faire du droit être
commissaire de police ou travailler dans
la police
j'ai toujours voulu faire ça et c'est
vrai que on en prend très peu 1000 à
1200 parents il fallait avoir une
maîtrise de droit
bon il faut que la vie s'est pas fait
comme ça et l'autre jour j'avais eu au
téléphone mon ami marc olivier fogiel et
je lui ai dit j'y pense de plus en plus
c'est quelque chose qui me passionne
aujourd'hui je cours plus après l'argent
ou la célébrité je crois pas quelque
chose qui me donnera l'impression de me
réaliser et il m'a dit mais mais il
n'est jamais trop tard français sur la
raison et la gentillesse
marc ollivier de me mettre en contact
avec un commissaire dont je tairai le
nom mais juste pas pour être pistonné de
navarre osé avec la vidéo allez-y
appelez moi
appelez-moi appelez moi je vais faire ma
part oui je confirme avoir de télé
internationales oui moi qu'est ce que tu
me débrouille toi j'ai une enquête en
cours son côté fait savoir si on fait
commissaire de police passe et 45 ans
pour moi mais tu vois bien moi j'étais
comme au cirque boli jusqu'à 92 ans pour
te connais tu commences à 40,58 tu nous
fais chier tu bouges pas été bons les
vieux le cerveau comme bout de huit ans
que je pense que quand tu as d'autres
questions de n'importe quoi je sais que
des dérogations mais encore une fois
c'est pas forcément dans la prétention
de démarrer commissaire on peut démarrer
brigadier-chef nageurs ont peut être
responsable d'une unité le tout mais
alors a45 ans c'est possible ou pas
mathieu alors normalement les amassé 35
ça peut jusqu'à 45 ans avec une
dérogation malheureusement j'ai 46
depuis quelques mois ça
le compliqué mais sinon l'examen
j'aurais pu le réaliser mais encore une
fois je peux aussi démarrer le mois
j'aimerais diriger une unité
j'ai évidemment aucun mépris pour j'ai
pas envie de commenter ça me saoule
greta les circulations ont dit la vérité
même si j'ai parfois démarré comme ça il
faut démarrer comme mais absolument de
toute manière moi je démarrais avec une
équipe
je veux un travail qui ait du sens je
sais que c'est pas un travail on y va
pour le pour le salaire et c'est
dangereux
j'ai toujours adoré ça gfr j'ai fait
plein de sujets dessus j'ai fait un
sujet sur la fluviale abrika nationale
que j'ai adoré et oui je me renseigne
pour passer l'examen pour c'est quelque
chose qui m'a toujours passionnée dans
matthieu vous y croyez vraiment écoutez
je vais juste vous dire quelque chose
qui est extrêmement prétentieux oui mais
jusqu'à maintenant tout ce que j'ai
voulu faire
j'ai réussi ce qui prouve bien qu'il
faut pas être un parent à part mes shows
mais un baiser un compas être
intelligent et faut le vouloir
il faut lever noirs même quand j'ai
voulu faire ouf je n'ai fait donc si
vous voulez non mais mathieu mathieu
donc vous y croyez vous voyez donc
l'année prochaine dans la police j'adore
reste l'année prochaine dans la police
je sais pas ce sera aussi pour passer
des examens je ne sais pas là je suis
sur le début d'un protocole je rencontre
des gens sans prétention pour voir
comment c'est possible je peux pas je
peux pas être que je peux vous proposer
quelque chose moi de transition
peut-être ça va faire deux gardes du
corps vous voulez toujours est à la
sécurité du plateau mais n'ont jamais
dirigé une équipe pas que je te met avec
moctar mais tu diriges une équipe je te
mets là je te mets tout le monde mais
ils bougent mais déjà je vais te dire
quelque chose avec tout ce que j'ai pour
toi parce que tu resteras toujours un
ami mais quand je leur ai fait six mois
de formation avec la police nationale
et que je te ferai niblett bras unique
chez de brad tu seras au sol et tu me
poses dû arrêter ouais tu verras que tu
feras moins le malin
d'accord je vais bien alors mathieu tu
veux le dire et je ne peux je suis on
mesure aujourd'hui à 18 heures s'est dit
de vous dire qu'après avoir entendu
mathieu de l'embout et ça me fait
extrêmement bien je suis en mesure de
vous dire à 100% il sera donc avec nous
l'année prochaine
pour aujourd'hui rendez-vous le 2
septembre
tu connais la grèce il faut se rendre à
l évidence tu as fait un record
d'audience hier j'étais pas là je pense
que mon heure est passée aujourd'hui
non mais mathieu vraiment alors tout
vous y croyez au projet de mathieu gsm
et andré gillet non non ça naturellement
c'est pas une blague et vous chez vous
est-ce que mathieu de lambeaux doit
partir dans la police dit oui ou dit non
moi très honnêtement j'aime trop la
police pour y croire la police ne mérite
pas ça interrogé par de l'or noir
mais alors il est très bon et beau elle
à la gilles gilbert briseur de rêves lay
my mind laurence mais moi j'y crois un
songe trouve ça génial et j'espère qu'il
va y arriver parce que franchement plus
il est hyper jeunes puisque on a le même
âge à peu près donc c'est bien d'eux
serait un monde et hop on attendait
mieux nous entoure
franchement bon après voilà je pense que
voilà tu me diras dans quel quartier tué
pour éventrer commettre commettre des
larcins par contout sans crainte devait
faire
dans quelle juridiction tu te trouve
bien au panama moi je pense pourquoi
toujours poursuivre s'élève peu importe
l'âge y a pas d'âge pour tomber ce que
c'est là justement qu'il actait mois les
chéri e
tout le monde a envie de se débarrasser
de matthieu delormeau c'est pas très
sympa pour votre code
le mec non j'ai qu'une envie c'est de
servir de ces deux navires de proies
pour des requins en afrique du sud mais
vous voyez alors des jumelles il va nous
manquer il va nous manquer leur équipe
et tous il décide de faire ça mais il
faut pas vous qu'il le fasse en étant
malheureux en citant qu'il joue quelque
chose il faut toujours aller au bout
d'une envie donc alors la synergie
dialogue qui seul tous les moyens les
chérit les chéris moi je vais faire un
petit tour de table a rapid vous dites
oui ni non
est-ce que vous pensez que l'année
prochaine matthieu delormeau sera
policiers première question est ce que
vous apprendrez que matthieu delormeau
sera dans tpm p alors attention on
démarre pas valérie bénaïm donc première
question et deuxième question alors
est-ce qui sera officiée non pas encore
lp oui il sera bon
benjamin castaldi est ce qui serait
policiers dès les prochaines nom et sera
tpp bien évidemment le rock ça y est
bikey castaldi nikos ça me semble un
petit peu juste mais moi je me demande
s'il a envie de rester en france
permettant la sofico
sophie cost on lui pose une question
c'est la nouvelle isabelle morini bosc
c'est la nouvelle il à mettre au tas
demandé oui ou non aller mairie s'était
confiné à des conflits nés là pour le
foot est confiné oui merci des confinés
lundi gilles verdez esquissera policiers
non est ce qui sera alors dpm mais bien
sûr je peux maintenant je peux donner
mon avis non est-ce qu'il sera policiers
non nous avons un pays non
l'arrivée de cette finale s'annonce
calme dans ma tête je suis sérieux je
veux devenir utile battait déjà été
utile tu ne fais du divertissement tu es
génial les gens tu adores tu as des
dowler meurs tu crois quoi tu vas être
policier tu crois que tu veux 3 tu vas
voir des de leurs moeurs
tu vas voir des gens qui me crachent à
la gueule parce que teinteront tourcoing
non mais voilà je devrais est un
policier dit pluie va lui ça va être un
policier difficile attention il ya des
polices est sympa il ya des policiers
sympa et c'est vrai et on en a besoin
d'ailleurs voilà on a besoin de tout
voilà mais matthieu delormeau
je peux vous dire enfin ne va pas
rigoler à lui tape at-on attestation
éclat fait bouffer par la lune dans tout
ce que je fais je suis toujours très
très raide faut vraiment que ce soit
5h15 y ait bien fait ça me fait juste
attention de pas vous tromper de
matraque c'est tout ce qu'on vous
demande de m non mais matt match en tout
cas vérité donné confiance
mathieu juste mon chéri tu sais qu'on
t'aime c'est pour ça qu'on dit ça si
nous ce qu'on veut c'est ton bonheur si
tu veux devenir policier l'année
prochaine alors juste j'aimerais savoir
maintenant quelles vont être les
prochaines étapes pour toi parce que les
téléspectateurs veulent savoir
donc là donc là on et voilà on est
confiné une fois qu'on est des confiné
donc qu'est ce que tu fais pour devenir
policier raku et ben justement pour
l'instant je vais rencontrer à un
commissaire qui a eu la gentillesse de
me 2 me de mela d'accepter de me
rencontrer je vais parler avec lui je
vais voir si c'est possible ou pas
d'atteindre comme quand vous êtes dans
l'armée cette année directement des
postes d'officiers avant même d'avoir eu
les premiers grades accord non pas du
tout comme comme au sein d'une existence
mais une équipe toulousaine e excusez
moi mais vont exactement
vous étiez à la télé quand on a dit
matters on a une équivalence au policier
local année non non il se trouve juste
mon chéri que contrairement à bouger
j'ai déjà fait des études puisque
j'avais une maîtrise de droit et
d'économie
voilà et après je vais voir est
effectivement à quel niveau avec ma
maîtrise je peux obtenir un grade
est ce qu'il faut faire et ce qu'il faut
pas passer un examen si c'est le cas oui
une formation et je commencerai au
niveau où je peux commencer je ferai pas
le malin vous savez l'humilie
et l'humidité dès le début de la
carrière d'accord alors voici je peux te
donner un conseil déjà pour commencer
cet été
c'est ce qu'on fait de nombreux
commissaires je vais te dire achète toi
pleymo commissariat le playmobil
déclenché à perdre deux trois
arrestations en playmobil tout ça tu
vois comment ça tu vois si ça ne peut
tirer si je deviens un policier et que
je t'arrête oui mais je peux te dire que
sur ma vie tu va bouffer et ben écoutez
c'est un vrai scoop contient la matthieu
delormeau veut devenir policier ça c'est
complètement fou car justement il ya
jimmy mohamed qui est là qui est un
petit peu ce qui est la raison aussi
dans cette émission jimmy vous avez ya
plein de questions pour jimmy notamment
puisqu'on aura du cese débat dans un
instant jenny mohamed vous justement est
ce que vous y croyez à matthieu
delormeau policiers l'année prochaine
est ce que vous voyez matthieu delormeau
rentrer dans les forces de l'ordre bah
écoutez moi je dis pourquoi pas je pense
qu'avec ce confinement se pose beaucoup
de questions mais je me pose énormément
de questions sur quel est le sens de
notre vie est ce que ce qu'on fait ça de
l'intérêt est donc peut-être que de
nouvelles perspectives vont s'ouvrir
pour mathieu et pour d'autres donc moi
je dis pourquoi pas parce
qu'effectivement on se pose beaucoup de
questions donc ce matin l'ouverture
oui ou non mais non mais la raison et
puis je pense qu'il est déterminé et
parfois on se pose la question
effectivement d'intérêt c'est vrai que
la télé c'est très bien c'est sympa mais
parfois ça a des côtés on va pas se
plaindre négatif donc peut-être que le
cours en asie russie et le temps des
bilans et puis s'il considère que le
bilan est positif va peut-être qu'il
sera autre chose qui a pensé à changer
d'orientation pendance coronavirus
castaldi est ce que tu as pensé toi moi
la seule salle vont réellement au
talonnage
non ce qui peut éventuellement me
m'amuser c'est de devenir prof de
plongée sous-marine voilà c'est le seul
métier auquel se pourrait inspirer ouais
bah t'es déjà sous l'eau c'est bon et
beau merci c'est gentil je veux qu'à
trouver les bonnes notes a plus qu'à
trouver les palmes et puis des
bouteilles d'oxygène non merci de l'ain
castaldi si demain on te dit épreuve de
plongée sous marine tu lâches tout ou
pas ah non non non
ah non mais cyril qu'un hobby ça mais
oui bah nan mais matthieu delormeau
regarde c'est une passion regarde
mathieu est ce que tu peux nous faire en
direct de chez toi
une arrestation c'est te plaît vas-y à
vas-y on est chez toi silva dit allez
vas-y alors attention non mathieu tu
sais quoi on est en face à face
je viens de commettre un larcin allez
c'est parti tu m'interroge allégations
bonjour monsieur police nationale ce que
je peux voir passer s'il vous plaît
j'étais déjà les noms et c'est déjà toi
désirez pas donné est ce que vous
connaissez la raison d'autres
arrestations monsieur bien entendu bien
sûr on peut me la donner oui oui vous
pouvez déjà changé ce petit ton insolent
s'il vous plaît à parler à une autorité
de la nationale et j'avoue devrait y
aller c'est d'un orthophoniste tu
comprends pas ce que vous dites alors ça
démarre très mal les à monsieur temps
éduqué en elle sa casquette on donne ses
papiers très tranquillement et puis si
vous le prenez sur ce ton ça peut soit
se passait très bien ici soit sinon ça
peut aller au poste pendant trois heures
moi j'ai tout mon temps
nous on est déjà au poste non les postes
on est dans la rue on a slamé ta gueule
tu vas brûler des papiers parce que tu
commences à me casser les couilles au
sujet des droits
j'ai des droits jeu de leur mort et vous
parlez pas comme ça car je connais pas
cet hiver ce qui vous êtes je vous ai vu
à la télé avec anouma
enfin thalassa pas les lois mais je de
leur mort et c'est vrai c'est pas parce
que vous êtes connu que vous avez des
droits supplémentaires monsieur hanouna
ça chiale en images il n'y a pas de nous
n'a mabiala de nous lors mathieu hiatus
bon on fait une deuxième scène
là je suis à au volant de ma voiture tu
m'arrête attention on va voir si tu as
les biens mis d'accord attention tu
tapes amadou ou way bonjour monsieur
prenez stationna halle
oui je viens de vous je suis derrière
vous depuis un petit moment vous avez
une conduite dangereuse
vous vous êtes derrière moi depuis
longtemps mais j'ai rien senti monsieur
c'est bien vous et l'humour mais c'est
dans deux minutes vous n'en aurez plus
donnez moi vos papiers vous étiez plus
de 50 km/h au-dessus vous allez donc
avoir un véhicule qui va être saisi
également le permis monsieur vous mettez
des enfants en danger
vous allez souple et déjà dans un ballon
pour voir si vous n'avez pas bu d'alcool
car vous avez sait pas qui est bien
c'est que j'ai pas bu d'alcool c'est
juste votre terre qui me revient pas oh
là là a alors là ce qui se passe ne
pourrait pas le voir je te dirai
monsieur sorti du véhicule une suite
sortez de quoi à sortait du véhicule de
votre grotte 4 4 noir est riche sortez
votre véhicule
alors je n'ai pas quatre pattes noires
par contre toi tu vas voir un gros 4 4
dans la gueule un cac à l'arrêt jeudi la
semaine je te prends une quête bras je
te pauillac sur le quercy sont honteuses
la claque sur le capot d'accord jamais
une première menottes je mets la
deuxième voilà pour être sûr de
maîtriser l'individu surtout lorsque la
personne comme toi et à fonctionner
et pour moi je vous le dis il est prêt
commissaire de lanvaux à partir de
maintenant on l'appellera commissaire de
leurs mots je vous le dis voilà allez
c'est fait on l'a en tout cas qu'il ya
plein de gens qui on va avoir la vie des
gens dans un instant qu'ils vont nous
dire s'ils sont contents ou pas que
matthieu delormeau change d'orientation
et on en sera un petit peu plus au cours
de cette émission matures du cas de
lambeaux savez vous pourriez faire
équipe avec moi ah non pas du tout non
pourquoi non moi je considère que la
police ait quelque chose de sérieux aux
locaux qui les commissaires mais où es
tu va redescendre pour l'instant t pas
commis certes rien du tout donc tu
fermes ta gueule et tu vas faire passer
la serpillière
ouais mais tu as vraiment du bol qu'on
soit au confinement et pas l'un en face
de l'autre la télé là encore la gueule
quand on est loin de là dedans ce
mathieu mathieu en tout cas mon chéri je
te souhaite de vivre tes rêves et si tu
veux que je t'ai de je serai là il
aimerait juste pour terminer c'est vrai
ce confinement a fait réfléchir à plein
plein de choses et déjà c'était pas dans
ma tête avant je ne suis pas dix lettres
policiers en quinze jours mais avant que
ça fait des années que j'y pense et là
tout d'un coup tu te dit certainement
oui
faire des choses utiles et je trouve que
tu as des choses utiles quand tu
dépasses 40 ans tout d'un coup tu as
envie de faire des choses vers de
l'authentiqué bien perte de choses
utiles
voilà bah regarder bab et naïma ben
voilà fait des brushings c'est utile
aussi à valérie match il y est ce que
toi ya pensé à changer d'orientation en
bonbons pendant ce que ce nombre en
station une orientation mais si par
hasard s'il advenait que je puisse lui
faire de la télé moi j'arrêterai et
jetterait des livres se consacrera
jusqu'à l'écriture c'est ma passion
c'est voilà je serais aujourd'hui très
bien ma chérie très bien gilles verdez
moi j'ai songé accorde encore coin quand
on sera quand on sera des consignes et
j'ai chanté son besoin de changer aller
en afrique pour aider à l'afrique
vraiment m'installer là-bas ya bravo
bravo et on en a besoin de personnes qui
est de la frappe bravo
laurent ça y est ah lala joy apprécié
par les républicains maintenant elle est
porte parole du tunisien donc voilà ça
c'est sophie koch c'est bien d'arriver
aussi et voilà tout le monde va bien
aller les chiffres en tout cas vous me
direz si vous voulez changer
d'orientation pas de problème juste
prévenez moi avant quelques semaines
avant justement puisse engager des gens
à moindre coût je vais tout arrêter
cyril tu dois arrêter la télévision la
production tu vends ta boîte où tu fais
quoi
alors franchement je fais quoi dans mon
avis à mon avis franchement je fais
alors je fais trois choses je fais du
jeu devient ou joueur professionnel de
poker ou joueur professionnel de paddle
même à 45 ans j'essaie voilà de deux
joué toute la journée elle jour et nuit
et je partirai quelquefois avec gilles
en afrique pour aider l'afrique voilà ça
beau choix
voilà c'est bien voilà c'est les trois
choses voilà que je ferais voilà je
partagerai en trois voilà donc gilles tu
m'auras sur le dos face toulouse je
t'aurais sur le dos à l'est